our social media analysis unit has
ramped up its monitoring of sites to
catch incitement to violence direct
threats to others and all this
is in response to our desire our strong
commitment to ensure that not only do
New
Yorkers be safe but they also feel safe
well yes we want to uh stop violent
crime but but even more than that we
want to stop hate and so stopping hate
means effectively stopping speech it
means it means punishing speech and
that's what she's describing there which
is the bit about monitoring social media
for hate speech and countering
negativity okay it shouldn't need to be
said that countering negativity is not
the government's job